[Music]
we found supermassive black holes so
large they defy explanation they're too
big to have grown by simply eating the
matter around them they can't form the
same way that regular black holes do
there must be something else that
happens that lets them grow to such
enormous mass too large to have grown
from dark stars and too big to have
grown from regular black holes simply
eating each other merging black holes
almost certainly play a role in our
understanding of supermassive black
holes we think that supermassive black
holes themselves also merge and have
merged regularly over the course of the
universe now whether this merging
activity itself is enough to make them
that big the jury is still out on that
now a newly discovered type of galaxy
may provide an answer it's called W 2 2
4 6 - 0 5 to 6 and we can't see it but
we can detect the heat it gives off this
galaxy is an example of a rare class of
objects called hot dogs one of the
funnier terms for an exotic type of
galaxy is a hot dog galaxy and know this
is not some delicious sausage snack in
fact it means hot dusk obscured galaxy
it's called obscured because it's
shrouded in so much dust and gas the
only light that escapes is infrared in
the form of heat all this heat must be
coming from somewhere so in the core
there is a caldron a seething
supermassive black hole the likes of
which we can't even imagine
of all the supermassive black holes we
know of the ones that are obscure these
hot dog galaxies maybe the ones that are
the most ravenous consuming many
millions of times the mass of the Sun
scientists theorize that hot dogs could
be the offspring of cannibal giant black
holes
when the monstrous black holes merge
they drag gas and dust with them this
brings more food to the table allowing
the new black hole to gorge itself
you